they warned of snow
and in some parts of the UK inches fell
in hours cloaking high hills in the
Yorkshire Dales
making morning commutes dangerous here
in Sheffield residence woke up to snow
that continued to get heavier throughout
the day schools across the city have
been shut and there have been warnings
that treacherous conditions could
continue until tomorrow
walking wasn't easy driving even harder
gritters have been out in force as the
Met Office warned of atrocious travel
conditions they used to be
busy looking at the weather forecast for
once
National highways closed roads in the
north of England were an amber alert has
been in place electricity companies here
also warned of power Cuts businesses
like the Sheffield Cafe saw slower trade
as customers stayed home with
hospitality it does have a huge impact
definitely just just due to trade you
know you won't see many people walking
around and it's just it's harder for
people to get get out especially in some
way like Sheffield where it's so hilly
places are essentially cut off when it's
like this
as more snow fell warnings spread
into North Wales
an island
Birmingham Airport delayed some flights
whilst runways were de-iced brushed and
plowed
but amidst A disruption
for some the weather brought moments of
joy
even a little bit of Wonder I come from
Indonesia so it is not have a snow in
Indonesia is this the first time you've
ever made a Snowman in your whole life
yeah this is my first time yeah it's
good more spring-like weather is not too
far away the worst of this cold blast is
forecasted to clear by Friday afternoon
Sky News